on this episode I talk about first
impressions the people surrounding you
Jerome Jarre and much more you ask
questions and I answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
gary vay-ner-chuk and welcome to episode
37 of the askgaryvee show fun fact about
the number 37 Ivan says take us back to
the day when you said yes to Jerome
Jarre what was it that made you believe
in him and his idea thanks
I've been great question for the ones
out there that don't know Jerome Jarre a
very famous vine or snapchat or
Instagram er and I started an agency
called grapes story a sister agency to
vaynermedia all those characters last
May where we represent the best talent
in the emerging content platforms to do
branded content things of that nature
Jerome beat me in rock-paper-scissors in
Toronto and what he won on stage Jerome
raised his hand and said I was doing Q&A
can I go up there and play you rock
paper scissors if I beat you can I have
coffee with you in New York I said yes I
got him up there and I was hell-bent on
beating him and if I won I swear my
children I would have never met with him
so just amazing how life really is he
wins pissed me off and you know three
months later I look at my calendar I'm
like what's my next meeting it's like
10:30 at night on a Tuesday I'm dead
just want to go home I'm like what's my
next meeting
Jerome I'm like what is this I clicking
I don't even know the name I click into
it for the details that's how my
calendar kind of I do and I'm like oh
this guy I literally thought I was like
all right how do I get there and spend
four minutes in this meeting get out of
there and go to sleep because I have a
5:30 flight which is like a 3:45 wake-up
call the next day I remember and and
Jerome started talking he's like look
there's a platform by and I've got all
in I'm an entrepreneur I've grew up in
France I went to China I learned how to
speak English by listening to crush it
on audio which played to my egos
that made me sit there longer and then
and then he just kept talking and
basically was deja vu it felt like I was
having a conversation 2006 except Jerome
was me and I was Eric Kastner my lead
developer that I've given a lot of shout
out to at Kastner give him a little love
here I was pitching Kastner in 2006
should I start a record label I'm even
know about agents and things like that
I remember saying should I start and
remember the moment in his office should
I start a record label to represent
these new youtube stars like me I should
have and but I let it go and Jerome was
talking I'm like this is the same moment
over again and so the energy my gut feel
the fact that I believed in what he was
talking about he wanted to do a festival
we turned it into an agency because
that's what I knew about and so that's
what that's what it was it was the
content the context and the intuition
and when I have that a CCI concoction I
always go with it Jim asks what's your
opinion on the auto reply DM services
Jim I really wanted to take this
question because I'm so glad you did it
and asked it and I appreciate it and I
want to say that I hate it it is
literally the thing that I despise the
most I have actively unfollowed many of
you because I followed you and you did
that and I unfollowed because it speaks
to the intent you have on the platform
which is to use it as a conversion
mechanism you're looking to scale social
media in a world where social media
especially on Twitter is not scalable if
you haven't figured out why I over
indexed it on the platform it's because
it's a non scalable platform when done
right because Twitter is the only true
social network everything else has
evolved into content push this is the
one place we all talk in a Town Square
environment and we can jump into each
other's conversations and it is not
creepy and when you go auto-reply in a
town square you're the guy walking
around the office and you're just
handing people your business card
without saying hello and nobody likes
that guy or gal at a conference or
networking event
blindly just handing a card without even
really engaging I think it's a terrible
move I think it turns off a lot of
people I think even if people don't
untie me I haven't because I'm just busy
and I haven't do you think you got my
follow or something good happened it's
the wrong move all you had to do was
engage with the people that followed you
twice for about six minutes which is
time I'm not saying it's not but you
could have gotten to depth you're
looking for so what I'm gonna sign up
for your newsletter and you're gonna
email me it's gonna go to spam and not
gonna engage because the first taste
that you have of someone
the initial context that first moment
that first impression when it's you've
lost tyler asks when have you been
happiest in life Tyler I took this
question for a very specific reason
because I think one of the interesting
things about the askgaryvee show is this
content an actual infrastructure has
forced me to go deeper than I have in
any other platform and it's been
interesting to watch what a lot of you
in the vaynernation have been responding
well to which is a little bit more
insight to my psychology and I think
this question gave me the opportunity to
answer it and I'm gonna really throw you
for an interesting curveball and this is
100% the answer I am the happiest in my
life of all time right this second
that's just the truth and what I mean by
that is is this moment what these
characters
show them you know you know do they know
d-roc actually do they know Alex Diaz
he's been sick for a couple days so he
looks terrible is this moment with these
characters the best moment of course not
last night beating the Cavaliers going
to Cleveland for LeBrons homecoming and
dominating and stunning the world it was
an amazing by the way
Cleveland you're gonna hate me for this
having given Cleveland a lot of love I
was disappointed with the fans this was
LeBron go son coming home and they it
wasn't enough like a random like second
round Knicks home game energy in the
garden was better I was very
disappointed not this thing and I know
Cleveland fans are awesome in there
I respect Cleveland it's a tough town
not a lot of championships for a long
time was disappointed I had to throw
that rub in there because that's how I
roll
um children being born Jets beating the
Patriots in New England in the second
round of playoffs after losing 45 to 3
in a Monday night game just a couple
weeks earlier way up there probably my
happiest moment my wife and kids know
but if you ask me happiness I'm a
collector I'm a momentum guy I'm a
chugger
and so you know every day that goes by
that good things keep happening and no
death and that's how I look at it is
happening in my family or sickness or
terminal conclusions to anybody I care
about feels like the next best day it
feels like it's always getting better I
don't know if one day look I'm gonna be
very honest with you guys in my deepest
fear because I'm positive I don't talk
about negativity my deepest fear is that
eventually I become bitter right that I
pushed the long game too long and I
didn't capitalized and I missed moments
but right now I still think I'm on the
climb I don't think I'm any other side
of the hill and so hopefully I always
have that psychology even to the last
breath that I take but to me the
happiest moment is right now because
everything is collectively always
getting better even when it's not you
know there's always gonna be challenges
it still is I just that's how I see it
chase asks how can you stand out on
LinkedIn with all the chatter from the
social media gurus that are spamming
everyone's feed chase I took this
question because I need to razz you and
everybody else who asks a question like
this but I want you to know that I love
you and I apologize this is a loser
question if you're worried about
everybody else you're not worried about
yourself and that's the bottom line
it is stunning how little I know about
anything else except my world and you
guys period end of story
I don't know how everybody else's
podcast is doing I don't I'm not listen
to anybody elses podcast or video show
or anything else I'm aware I know that
I'm between 60 and 80 on the podcast
ratings but I don't look at Tim Ferriss
who's higher or somebody ups and listen
to it and trying to figure it out I
focus on my stuff way too many people
cry oh these social media gurus are
loud they're loud but if they don't have
depth they're gonna weed themselves out
and so if you spend one minute looking
at what anybody else is doing
versus spending all your time about what
is your audience care about and how are
they reacting to your stuff you'd only
spend my hour on when I'm like winding
down instead of looking at who's ratings
are higher and then trying to copy their
moves or complain that they're putting
out shows longer or better or different
things or get guests or this and that
instead of focusing on their context and
their competitive advantages or what
they're doing well what I do is I read
my comments that's what I do because I
really care about what you guys are
saying about this show where the value
prop is what your opinion on the website
is what your opinion about chugging is
what your opinion about banter is
because that's how I'm collectively
trying to make this show better I'm
focusing on the people that give a crap
about this and so instead of worrying
about what everybody else is doing
I don't even it's crazy and I think you
can see my energy on this I know this is
a huge huge you know in lieu of the
marathon coming to New York this weekend
I am NOT a runner who looks around me
I'm like straight ahead that analogy
that people views this not my analogy I
have a lot of my own oh by the way we
are the reverse engineer shirt right
let's link that up that's up did I blow
it you put it on T public and only is
like for 72 hours where it's $14 and
goes to 22 that's right so we need to
like I need to put a fit do I have IBS
you can I post I need to put I'm gonna
post this on Facebook it's already up by
the time you watch this because D rocks
got some editing to do D right did I
ruin your Halloween did we start too
late here like what time is this gonna
be done okay my friends stopped paying
attention to everybody else who gives a
[ __ ] I need a lot of beeps in this
episode because I want to keep it clean
for the podcast who gives a crap what
everyone other social media guru Dan
expert if they're attracting an audience
maybe they're doing something right it's
not up to you to decide they're a fluffy
crappie guru and they don't deserve it
clearly they're hustling and putting out
stuff and clearly they'll stay don't
forget I've been around since oh six
under this kind of monarchy and this is
the interesting thing there's a lot of
people that were the social media
technology gurus in 2000 79 that you
never heard of they come and go if
they're not good enough and if they're
good enough they stay Khalil says sup
Khalil this is a great question I'm
actually gonna take more stuff questions
so if you want to sneak your way into
the askgaryvee show the next couple of
months I want to do way more sup so I
would highly recommend tweeting that out
here's what's up I'm gonna be leaving
shortly just got back from Cleveland had
a great moment me and AJ have decided
not buying stuff is the way to go we
don't stuff we want experiences so we
decided to go see LeBrons first game
because we expected the cleveland
stadium to explode pregame and when he
got announced did not happen I'm just
saying Cleveland and so we want to buy
experiences so we made that decision
then the fact that the Knicks ended up
playing that made it so much more
awesome AJ surprised his assistant Tyler
let's go see Tyler people for example
here's a good moment I wasn't even
thinking about Tyler I was even thinking
about Tyler but because a lot of you are
saying we want you to leave the office
more often and go show everybody what do
they all do I've decided to do it so
we're gonna go see Tyler really quick
just real quick Tyler
speak to the vaynernation let's go baby
were you surprised like how you went for
the high-five and I just to make a
comment about that were you excited when
AJ surprised you to go to the game Oh
but DeMeo demands right here the sugar
mayo a selfless act de Mayo
what we decided to do was we were going
to take one of them and flip a coin but
the Mayo said Tyler did most of the
legwork let him go a selfless act he's a
man go Knicks he's waiting for his
Yankees World Series so that's it right
so you wanted more of the office you got
more gift you know what one thing we
haven't done is we haven't gone
downstairs what people don't know is and
the other thing is we haven't shown him
the other side so we can show them one
thing we haven't done is shown you how
deep it really goes so like it goes
further you can give them a little there
so look and there's a downstairs when we
get through the downstairs Oh Nick you
want to be on the show so that's that
that's um that's uh what's up you know
Nick's we surprise Tyler we uh we're
doing the show
leaving in a couple hours to go Go Daddy
Rock we leave in a couple hours in about
an hour to take the take the kids
trick-or-treating so that should be
exciting leaving early you know it's
exciting I'm in that chapter of my life
now where not only am i leaving earlier
to go to trick-or-treating and when I
would never do that even like in my mind
three years ago and don't forget to be
sure was already born but not only am i
leaving I don't even think twice and
that's a nice place to be so that's
what's up we're like the health and
family of clearly in the last 24 months
on family three months on health they
have now trumped my work life so that my
work life is stronger that's an
evolution within my world but I'm
working harder probably than ever like
it's insane the hustle so that's up Jets
suck that's up that's pissing me off
Wine Library calm Steve is doing an
incredible job I mean I would say
basically at this point we're like still
hacking at it but like editor like if we
go that route we're really excited about
the content we're putting out there
check that out
wine is starting to line starting to
creep back into the
DNA that's up we're uh we're excited
about the show man I'm really enjoying
this guy's like by the way it's insane
how much I'm enjoying this right now but
I've and this is where I'm linked
bathing a little bit I'm not kidding I
am a complete animal of like success and
like the engagement so lurkers I'm gonna
end the show we're done right workers
I'm gonna speak to you you guys are my
key focus right now because I know a lot
more of your watching but you're not
leaving comments you're not critiquing
the show you're not giving me my banter
you're not saying hello you're starting
to pop out so a bunch of people pop up
on Twitter but I need a little more from
you on that the other thing is I know I
made the joke today about the number 37
right no more of that I talked about
that one of the interesting things that
I've been looking at is doing something
called like app of the day in the
beginning like you know kind of like
what apps are on my phone like why is
tiny there when tiny came out like so
that's kind of been on my mind a little
bit of that that's up a lot of things
are sup I appreciate the question and I
appreciate all of you I'm not gonna
leave you with a question today today
instead I'm gonna challenge you to leave
comments without one and I expect the
vaynernation
to accept but thank you guys for
allowing me to do this show you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe